nearly 20 years after the final film in
the trilogy some fans are still
scratching their heads over various
elements of the Matrix series so now
we're taking a look at the most
confusing scenes and the franchise and
finally explaining these matrix moments
The Matrix primarily takes place from
Neos point of view and in his world he's
just a random guy who happens to be a
really good hacker that all changes when
he's contacted by Morpheus brought out
of the matrix and told he's the one
Morpheus seems to believe neo is his man
with absolute certainty but what the
film never tells us is how he knows neo
is the one the short answer is that it
doesn't matter to the story because
we're meant to experience it from Neos
perspective as someone coming to term to
the news that he's a messiah but if we
really want to dig deeper the film makes
it clear through action that Morpheus in
addition to being a leader of the
resistance is an expert hacker the film
also makes it clear that neo was gained
a reputation as someone who seems to
question the nature of his reality neo
has also heard of Morpheus before and
has expressed curiosity about him in the
past
therefore it's likely that Morpheus had
been observing neo for some time before
the events of the film and that he came
to the conclusion that neo was the man
he was looking for Morpheus did the
legwork
it's just legwork we don't get to see on
the screen I can guide you but you must
do exactly as I say in the matrix
Morpheus explains to neo that the matrix
exists as a simulation to occupy the
minds of humanity and make them think
that they're living a normal life
in reality the matrix exists because the
machines have enslaved all of humanity
for the purposes of power humans are
living batteries kept alive in pods and
vast farming complexes to supply energy
to the machines civilization this of
course faced an important question
while a new machines try to find other
sources of power as Morpheus also
explains and the matrix humans scorched
the sky during their war the machines
because at the time the machines were
primarily dependent on solar power
since the polluted skies of Earth make
it impossible for the machines to feed
on the Sun they use the humans as a new
power source but what about fossil fuels
or hydroelectric power
well the matrix takes place at some
point in the future so it's possible the
machines simply used up the remaining
fossil fuel as for water and wind power
those could have been crippled by the
permanent loss of the Sun and the chaser
earth's ecosystem even if they weren't
though who's to say the machines haven't
tried those in the past or are still
trying them now the machine world is
fast they might use more than one pala
sauce after freeing neo from his part
Morpheus takes him to meet the Oracle a
prophet with a thing for baking cookies
and smoking cigarettes the Oracle spends
a little time alone with neo before
basically telling him that he's not the
one the thing is neo is the one that's
established firmly by the end of the
film the Oracle is supposed to know
everything so what does she steer near
wrong if you look at the scene again neo
is actually the one who saves the words
another one sorry kid you got the gift
but it looks like you're waiting for
something shaken by the news neo presses
her for more details and that's when the
Oracle tells him about the importance of
Morpheus to the resistance movement she
also tells him how much Morpheus
believes in him to the point that she's
sure one of them will die as a result
this inspires neo to stay close to
Morpheus and rise to the occasion of
saving his life at the end of the film
putting him on the path of the one so
the Oracle always knew neo was the one
but she judged him as someone who wasn't
ready to hear that he needed to have
faith in himself first by telling him
what she did
the Oracle pointed neo in the right
direction in the Matrix franchise a
human resistance movement is forced to
live underground with limited resources
and weapons however one of these weapons
is especially effective in the war
against the machines we're talking about
a device that generates an
electromagnetic pulse or EMP that knocks
out any electronic equipment and the
vicinity these devices are used to
create effective offensive weapons that
allow humans to neutralize nearby
machines as a last resort to live and
fight another day so why don't the
humans start using them offensively well
for one I MPs have drawbacks they knock
out the machines but they also kill any
electronic equipment the humans are
using including their hovercrafts and
computers this means no one can be
jacked into the matrix when an EMP is
used or they will die in the process for
another there are simply too many
machines to make offensive use of EMPs
practical their effect is only temporary
and even if every human hovercraft
launched a full assault on the machine
city that barely reached the outskirts
before having to activate
every EMP lit had it once to defeat the
first wave of machine sentinels another
wave would surely follow and there be
overrun in the world of the matrix Zion
is the last human city an underground
refuge where the resistance movement is
headquartered and the human race
continues to fight for survival
every resistance mission is launched
from there and hundreds of thousands of
people live in freedom or they work to
wipe the machines out entirely meanwhile
the machines have clearly bought various
systems in place to counteract human
resistance from agents to sentinels and
their resources of us so why haven't the
machines wiped out Zion as the architect
explains and The Matrix Reloaded Zion is
allowed to exist by the machines because
the concept of resistance centered
around the prophecy of the one is a
machine creation it was generated to
make humans resisting the matrix feel
that they have a choice in the eyes of
the machine
Zion is a necessary evil that must exist
so the matrix can persist and their key
source of power can remain in place in
the Matrix Reloaded agent Smith shows an
immense power to copy himself onto
others within the matrix creating a
sizable clone army he then expands our
ability to the real world when he
possesses a resistance member Bain via a
phone line Smith then exists in the real
world through Bane's body but how is
that possible well Smith is a computer
program created by the machines as an
enforcer within the matrix who's been
freed via Neos attempt to destroy him in
the first film so in the first movie
Smith is basically an antivirus program
however in the last two movies he
essentially becomes a software virus
himself able to replicate and spread
through contact the humans living in the
matrix had grown by the machines and
designed to receive software through the
ports built into their flesh Smith is
basically using that same principle to
transmit its own code into Bane's brain
possessing him as for how he can survive
in there without a connection well these
humans have certain tech built into them
that's how the machines made the
illusion of the matrix persist and how
the resistance does things like TM sells
martial arts for software Smith is
basically just hijacking that innate
stuff for his own nefarious purposes in
the Matrix Reloaded
neo meets the architect the program that
designed the matrix and the two have a
lengthy conversation about what's going
to happen next but many fans both when
the film came out and now this scene
sort of grinds the mood
two a-holes after all the architect is a
deliberately humorless analytical being
who speaks well like a computer program
might speak concordantly while your
first question may be the most pertinent
you may or may not realize it is also
the most irrelevant so what's the
architect really trying to say it's a
little complicated but it breaks down
like this the resistance movement isn't
an entirely human creation the prophecy
of the one was generated by the machines
and their assistance is allowed to
persist because of an anomaly in which a
small percentage of the population
rejects the matrix as their true reality
by allowing a human resistance movement
the architect can course correct this by
creating the illusion of choice the one
is also a machine creation and contains
a special code that reboots the matrix
each time he returns to the source
continuing the cycle of humans
subjugation the architect explains as to
neo and gives him a choice he can go to
the source and be given the opportunity
to repopulate sion and we start the
cycle or you can save trinity and by
extension kill the human race neo
chooses trinity and his love for her
introduces a new variable that the
architects did not foresee leading to
the next film at the end of the Matrix
Reloaded neo manifests a new power and
neutralizes several machines with this
mind but he falls into a coma
immediately afterwards at the beginning
of the Matrix Revolutions Neos body in
the real world is still in a coma
but his matrix form wakes up in a subway
station where Rama contra and his family
are waiting ramacandra explains at a
train station which they can only leave
on the train man's train as a kind of
limbo
it's a waypoint for rogue programs being
smuggled into the matrix by the
Merovingian to avoid deletion by the
source so how did neo get there the
Oracle explains in the video game ends
the matrix at when he lashed out of the
machines neo and wittingly touched the
source but entered limbo rather than
dying that's not the most concrete
explanation ever but at least that
explains why Neos body and minds were
separated in the Matrix Reloaded the
Oracle explains too near that the matrix
is full of rogue programs who refused to
go back to the source for deletion when
they were intended so instead that they
live a somewhat hidden life often
pursuing various criminal enterprises
while simply trying to survive because
they like existing these include the
mirror
vin jian his twin enforces the trainman
the key-maker and many others at the end
of the Matrix Revolutions
The Matrix has rebooted after neo
fulfills his end of the bargain with the
machines and defeats Smith by sending
him back to the source so what does a
reboot mean for all of those rogue
programs the short answer is actually
not much while Smith had all traces of
him was seemingly deleted at the end of
the film we see the rogue program satis
still alive at the exact moment of the
reboot the matrix online later reveals
that characters like the Merovingian are
also still alive and doing their thing
in fact the Merovingian remains one of
the oldest programs on the matrix which
suggests that he survived multiple
reboots so rebooting doesn't necessarily
mean cleaning up everything historically
it was usually about the machines trying
to repeat the cycle of humans
subjugation at the end of revolutions as
signals a fresh start for humans more
than it does the matrix in the Matrix
Revolutions Nia realizes Agent Smith has
become too powerful for the machines to
defeat and so he strikes a deal with the
robotic overlords offering to take care
of Smith once and for all the machines
agree and neo uses Smith's obsession
with him to launch a fight he then
allows Smith to try to copy him while
he's directly connected to the sauce
this sends Smith back to the sauce waste
elite said and the matrix reboots while
the machines are cretan Neos terms of
peace with the human race the downside
of this of course is that neo gives his
life in the process but the Oracle cast
doubt on his permanent death saying at
the very end of the film that she thinks
we might see him again obviously we know
now this is true because a fourth Matrix
film starring Keanu Reeves is on the way
but why does the Oracle think this how
can neo come back from the dead well
because he was pre-programmed to be the
one neo is partially software even more
than the other humans born in pods so
theoretically a program could be built
from the remnants of his code that
approximates his mind and personality in
fact one of the early storylines and the
matrix online video game centers on that
idea
passive neo are out there even if
they're fragmented the trick is bringing
those fragments together as something
that actually retains the essence of neo
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the bell to you know miss
a single one
[Music]